The past. Strangely, there are people today who think life was better back in the days of yore.
But why? Consider Louis Quatorze, the Sun King. Louis chose from 40 dishes every night,...
...taking 498 people to prepare each meal. He was rich because people did things for him,...
...and because others were poor. But today's average person can go into a supermarket...
... and buy a fresh, frozen, tinned, smoked or pre - prepared meal made with...
...beef, chicken, pork, lamb, fish, eggs, potatoes, beans, carrots,...
...or he can choose to eat from scores of nearby restaurants.
Italian, Chinese, Japanese or Indian, each of which has a team of skilled chefs...
...waiting to serve at less than an hour's notice.
Add all of this up and you realize that you have far more than 498 servants...
...at your beck and call.
Of course, these people work for many other people too, but what's the difference?
In a sense, we're all kings now.
Exchange in specialization means you no longer have a wick - trimming footman...
...but a switch that gives you instant light, thanks to hardworking people...
...at the grid of distant nuclear power stations.
You have no woodcutters to bring you logs for a fire.
Instead, you have the operators of gas rigs in Russia bringing you central heating.
This is collective intelligence, where everybody is working for everybody else...
...to bring us whatever we need.
And that's why things are getting better and better for humankind.
So it's time to put the past where it belongs: in the past.
And greet the future with rational optimism.